Mr snow
after everything you've seen out there
in the world
what are the Hunger Games for
[Music]
coming
The Hunger Games they're to punish the
districts those tributes don't have a
choice
[Applause]
Your Role is to turn these children into
spectacles not survivors
more lives
smile it's why we have teeth
I just want to know that somebody still
cared about me that I was still a value
welcome to the Capitol you look like you
shouldn't be here I shouldn't but I'm
your Mentor a rebel
I am gonna get you out of here if you
want to protect people
then it's essential to accept what human
beings are
God
what it takes to control them
do you use that famous snow charm
you seem like a good man cry Elena snow
I have seen what war does to people
filled with the terror becoming prey
luckily we become predator
I want my enemies to see a rainbow of
Destruction
engulfing the world
the monsters all of you
good luck with that poor little Songbird
where is she
of driving people
no let me ask you one final time what
are the Hunger Games for
[Music]
it's the things we love most and destroy
us